is one of the North Sea's largest
underwater gasping it's called Northern
Light at 40 kilometers long and ten
kilometers wide and containing over 300
billion cubic meters of gas
it's simply massive but it's locked in
an icy to 3000 metres below the surface
so deep and so remote that it's
considered beyond the reach of man and
machine and that is until the engineers
at norske drove the Norwegian energy
company decided it's just too tempting
to ignore me because there is enough gas
to supply 20 percent of Great Britain's
gas needs for 40 years it will take 10
years and cost ten billion dollars first
they'll drill the Ormen Lange gas
deposit transport the gas 120 kilometres
to one of Norway's largest processing
plants at nyhamna then sent the
processed gas to the UK down the
Langlade pipeline a staggering 1,200
kilometres the pipes are each 12 metres
long and weigh 10 tons with another 10
tons of concrete and metal is added to
give them enough weight to stay on the
ocean floor each of the 100,000 pipes is
numbered as it comes out of the plan
destined for a specific location in the
line the pipe laying itself is a
monstrous job once the pipe is being
manufactured it is placed onto the
supply ships for delivery to the pipe
laying barge the lb 200
the barges huge longer than two football
fields
it's an enormous floating steel welding
factory which has to work with military
precision the pipeline is built as a
continuous tool it has dropped from the
ship to the seabed if the ship halts for
too long the strain on the pipe could
snap this is no ordinary welding
operation the process involves a special
welding machine with eight heads per
station
passing through each of the welding
stations in seven minutes the pipe is
then checked by an ultrasound machine if
applause detected it has to be repaired
immediately before moving to the next
station after all the welding stations
have linked the pipe the final step of
the operation is to seal the exposed
metal
it is covered in a protective heat
shrunk plastic without this the steel
pipe is broken
the most critical step of the operation
offloading the pipe to the seafloor
as the pipe enters the ocean it begins
to sack and pressure is put on the
entire pipeline which is free hanging
beneath the ship without exactly the
right tension the fight could snap like
a matchstick the pipe comes off the back
of the barge who must call a lazy-s
configuration that s of unsupported pipe
has to be kept from just buckling under
its own weight
so to keep it under control you've got
to keep that under a huge tension to
stop it from just collapsing under its
own weight as the pipe is lowered the
barge moves forward 24 meters not a
meter more with this well-oiled
operation the lb 200 is able to lay over
100 kilometres of pipeline a month